the cliffhanger is one of the most
important weapons writers can have in
their arsenal when done right
cliffhangers can leave the audience
breathless dying to see what happens
next again there are some endings that
just dangle off that cliff forever
here are some famous cliff hangers that
will never have a resolution Spider Man
the animated series back in the 90s one
of the few bright spots for the then
struggling Marvel Comics company was
spider-man the animated series which
ended on a humdinger of a cliffhanger
Peter discovered his new bride Mary Jane
was actually a clone after the real MJ
was knocked through an interdimensional
portal by Green Goblin the plan was for
Spidey to rescue her at the beginning of
the sixth season but after a dispute
between execs at Marvel and Fox the
network abruptly ended the series the
show's head writer later apologized the
traumatized fans who are still wondering
if Mary Jane ended up just stuck in
another dimension forever Planet of the
Apes the movie or the planet at the end
of Tim Burton's poorly received 2001
version of the Planet of the Apes Mark
Wahlberg travels through time pursued by
his evil ape mimesis Stade Wahlberg
seemingly wins but when he returns to
present-day Washington DC he discovers
that the Lincoln Memorial is now
dedicated to fade instead of aid so how
did this happen and what does it mean
for Wahlberg and humanity those are
questions that will never be answered as
Burton said he'd rather jump out a
window than make a sequel what no my
name is 0 for 4 seasons Jason Leigh's
do-gooding lottery winner went around
checking things off his karma building
to-do list but there's one thing my name
is Errol didn't check off the
resolutions of this series cliffhanger
which promised to reveal the real
parentage of Earl jr. fans were
especially irate that NBC cancelled the
series considering the finale had a to
be continued graphic there were some
discussions between show creator Greg
Garcia and TBS about continuing the
series to provide closure to fans the
costs proved too high the event NBC
heavily promoted the event built around
the idea of an impending end
Siddhant that would change humanity
forever at the end of the first season
viewers learned that the event was
aliens creating a massive vortex that
brings their entire planet into orbit
next to earth oh and the president's
wife revealed she's secretly one of the
aliens so the president has an alien
baby mama
who wrote this Jerry Springer
unfortunately for fans ratings dropped
like a rock after the over-hyped
premiere and the series was canceled
series creator Nick waters promised that
one way or another they would continue
the story but so far that hasn't
happened talk about it non-event B the
series when the alien invasion opus VIII
debuted on NBC is a miniseries in May
1983 it captured the imagination of the
United States with an astounding 40% of
the country tuning in but while creator
Kenneth Johnson pushed for the story to
continue with a series of two our movies
NBC wanted a sequel miniseries followed
by a new weekly series so Johnson did
what any creative type might he quit NBC
went forward without him but the
resulting series was somehow both
expensive to make and also pretty poorly
done
the final episode had multiple
cliffhangers with human visitor hybrid
star child Elizabeth Maxwell agreeing to
return what their leader to the visitors
planet her boyfriend stowing away on
their shuttles and Diana planting a bomb
on the ship and then well nothing
because NBC canceled the series but it
wouldn't be the last time fans of D
would be left hanging
ABC revived fee is a brand new series in
2009 and in doing so the network ignored
all that came before except for having
ladies eating rodents and totally
messing with fans by going out on an
unresolved cliffhanger this time around
the lizard queen completely conquered
earth would the last fugitive humans
literally going underground to lead a
resistance movement and as far as we
know they're still down there somewhere
huddling in the dark waiting for a third
season that will never arrive poor sad
fools survivors the feel-good BBC drama
survivors featured the joyous premise of
Earth's population being almost totally
wiped out by a super flu released by an
evil corporation how many millions
infection carries on progressing on the
car right talking more than 90 percent
of the world's population at the end of
the second season Tom a former convict
who found his redemption over the course
of the series goes away on the
corporation's plane angry armed and
waiting and hiding to exact revenge
it was the BBC though that got his
revenge on the show for giving them poor
ratings by never airing a third season
that's sick the river when famous
explorer Emmet Cole disappears while
seeking the secret of magic in the
Amazon his family decides to take cruise
up the Amazon River and find him in
ABC's 2012 found-footage series the
river which had none other than Steven
Spielberg and Paranormal Activity
creator or IntelliJ and those famous
names meant exactly squat when it came
to ratings
which is too bad some fans because the
series ended with the shocked twist the
mystical spirit of the Amazon itself
actually warped reality to strand
everyone in the middle of the jungle
just as they seem to have made their
escape
Netflix considered picking up the show
for a second season but wisely opted
against it because why mess with angry
gods if you don't have to the Italian
Job the original 1969 version of The
Italian Job featured superstar Michael
Caine teaming up with a bunch of crooks
to feel four million in gold they get
away with the loot but in a last-second
twist their escape vehicle goes off a
cliff with all the golden sides not to
worry though because Caine has a plan to
deal with this literal cliffhanger hang
on a minute ledge was a great Mickey
just what that great idea was though
nobody ever found out like that bus
almost certainly did the film itself
also crashed and burned and the planned
sequel was never made thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]